[Music]
hello this is grandmaster brian smith
welcome to insane in the end game at the
st louis chess club where we discuss end
games
we're going to be talking about one of
the peculiarities of end games in
general here and that's that
in the end in the ending
it's very common to not want it to be
your move
whereas in the middle game usually you
prefer to be your move in any position
in any position there are exceptions of
course but
generally you want it to be your move
because you can do something but in the
end game this is often a serious uh
fatal even a state of affairs to have to
make a move
and based on this
uh most end games depend on this
for um
the result
so a simple example which is well known
the so-called trebuchet is this position
a very basic position
and whoever's move it is
wins because
you can lose a move by playing for
instance as white king e6 not king e5
after king e5 king c4
and white would have to make a move and
then lose
black would take the pawn on d4
but white can lose a move by king e6
attacking the pawn forcing black to
respond and then king e5
with uh with um
then black having to move away and white
takes the pawn on d5 and wins
likewise if it were blacks to move black
to move then
it would be the same thing king c3
king e5
protecting the pawn and then king c4
putting white into song
okay this is the most basic example and
i hope you're still
watching because i assume most people
know this but we're going to be covering
some much more complicated examples
let's start off with this uh
very famous and interesting example from
analyst named santorini
who
who analyzed deeply are basically all of
the bishop and pawn versus bishop
endings and uncovered many of their
secrets
this i believe was 1856 or at least
that's what i have written down
how can white win here
i'm going to ask from the uh
from the uh
um
i'm going to ask from the audience or
from the people online
people who haven't ever studied this
ending
hopefully what kind of plan can white
use to win this game can white win it is
it a draw or is it a win for white note
that the pawn can't queen because the
bishop's covering the cleaning square so
what's the first step of the plan
we need to well we can try deflecting
the bishop but how
sorry in the audience i can't see you
that well but if you
probably if you raise your hand i can
so what's what's the plan
bring bishop to b8 okay
trent says bring the bishop to b8
okay very good so how would we do that
james says deflect and then obstruct
bishop h4
okay very good aniket i think knew the
good the the way to win so he starts off
threatening to come to b6 or rather to
b8
so if for instance black doesn't attempt
to prevent white if black just waits
then white easily carries out his plan
obstructing the black bishop okay now
the pawn is blocked by white's bishop so
white can move away
black can stop the pawn from queening
and now how does white
queen the pawn
bishop g1 yes very good
bishop g1
and the pawn
or rather the bishop is uh
deflected away from a7 and white wins
okay
but black doesn't have to allow white to
carry out the plan so easily
rather than bishop g4 as aniket said
black can bring the king
over to a6 to try to stop bishop a7
so king b6
what now
this way black king will come to a6
defending the a7 square preventing
white's bishop from
coming there and
and reaching b8
anyone
uh bishop d8 would just repeat the
position
if bishop d8 then king would go back to
c6 and we have the same position we had
at the start
tariq says bishop f2
okay the ship of two threatening or
trying to come to a seven black prevents
it and what now
any kid says his carrot telling us the
plan
so when the bishop's not on h2
if the bishop's not in h2
then when the white bishop comes back it
will be attacked and white will gain a
tempo
okay well we we could do that yeah
bishop g1
or other
waiting moves
um
if bishop g1 the problem is that black
would have some move like
bishop here and white still can't come
back to d8
so if then you come back here black will
go back to his
safe spot for the bishop on age two
where white won't be able to attack it
so we need to use a different method
anyone see another waiting move white
could make with a bishop
to give black the move if black could
sit here nothing white could do
any kid says bishop c5 very good bishop
c5 would work
i chose in
my solution bishop e3 or santorini also
i think is but bishop c5 the same
concept would also work
um
so black has to move the bishop because
otherwise there's there's no way to skip
a move here
so unfortunately for black he has to
move bishop g3
and what now
how do we continue from here
bishop g1 black just continues waiting
and what
let's go back to this position
any kid says bishop g5
threatening to come back to c7
okay
if the bishop had been on c5 bishop e7
would also work
to either way bishop
g5 threatening bishop d8 bishop c7
which would win the game
so black has to stop that by bringing
the king back to cover c7
so king b6
and now bishop d8
king c6
and then as
both aniket and tariq said
bishop h4
gaining a key tempo
first white lost a tempo making it black
smooth forcing the bishop to move to g3
and then gains a tempo
for the transfer of the bishop back to
b8 now black has can't take the bishop
so bishop has to back off
or go elsewhere but in any case the
result is the same and what now
bishop of two avinash's bishop f2
again we're going back to this plan to
go to b8 but this time black doesn't
have time
with the king to move it to a6 because
of that key bishop h4 gaining a tempo by
attacking black's bishop
so for instance if king b5
and then white goes bishop a7 king a6
and black is not in time bishop b8
bishop g1 and the final step is bishop
retreats bishop a7 and black's bishop is
now on the short oops short diagonal
covering b8 this is the long it has two
diagonals to cover that square
from the long diagonal diagonal the
bishop can only be chased away by
opposing it on b8
it can't be deflected but from the short
diagonal it can be deflected without
white having to occupy b8 and block his
own pawn they are for bishop of two
and white wins same thing if black
doesn't try to transfer the king after
bishop of two then it's all very simple
black moves a bishop
and white comes around
retreats to make room for the panda
queen
black moves the bishop to the short
diagonal
and bishop g1 deflects the bishop then
so i think this is really beautiful and
just imagine 1856 when santorini
was uncovering these kinds of positions
and so were others there were no
computers around
people were just discovering basic
positions like this and finding kind of
artistic
solutions and this is the only solution
i mean there are many
possible
permutations of the same solution
obviously as
as was said white could have done bishop
c5 bishop d4 bishop e3
but it's the same concept the only way
to win is by this concept
now yes some people are asking jessica
pott asks if you can win the same way
with the c pawn let's imagine
can white
in this position you're reached but we
move it all over one
rank let's just uh
visualize it what move would black have
would black have to relinquish control
over what would be the c8 square by
taking on g1
or is there some other move
again we're moving this all over one
one file to the right
black would have one more
filed over here the bishop would have
three squares instead of two so bishop
a6 exactly
bishop a6
but here because of the edge of the
board white wins so with a c pawn now
the position is drawn to start
there are a lot of rules about bishop
and pawn endings we're not going to
cover them because we're just showing
this example but
um
different positions different methods of
winning but generally if the defending
bishop has more squares on both
diagonals then then they can draw
okay let's go to the next one
we looked at the trebuchet
and i'll show you
a way in which
i managed to use the same concept
this was a game i played a long time ago
well white has some pressure on c6 and
at this point i decided to
sacrifice on c6 and transpose to a rook
ending or upon ending depending on what
black did
and here black went rook c1 protecting
the bishop otherwise i take the bishop
and come back with the rook to a6
so here black now waited with the rook
or now it's white move sorry after rook
c c one
i want to take on c6 but it's not yet
time
so i played king g4
uh one tempo is i need to gain a tempo
at this point to go into the king and
pawn ending
this is uh
this is the uh
the case that in a lot of endings that
that you
you may want to wait again
you may want to win a tempo
or you may want to lose a tempo
depending on the situations and
sometimes one right after another in
this case
i want to gain a tempo now my opponent
played this move and actually he had
some ways to try to defend by staying in
the rook ending
for instance well at the time i thought
rook d won
and then back here and this position
this is winning for white i believe but
he had even slightly better uh defense
which would be to first check my king
instead of rook to d1 first check the
king with rook g1
and then go back to do that same thing
and i think he would have good chances
to draw but that's not what happened he
went rook c4
so question is can i go into the king
and pawn ending by trading rooks and
what happens then
yeah black's king is
uh okay so here
if i go king h5 but as someone said on
here rook takes d4
and that would then rook c6 the king
would move back and then f4 is hanging
and rook a4 is planned so i think black
would be okay question is yeah
i some people say i can go into the
ending let's let's calculate
so i took
he takes
pawn takes he has to deal with this pawn
so he takes
and now
am i going for a race with king h5
and then his king goes
or am i doing something else
a4
if a4 i believe black could go king b6
and go to take the pawn
and and it's another race
and i think it comes out
equal
i think both sides queen
so not a4
any cat says f5 so yeah we can easily
calculate king h5
okay black is coming here
takes
which pawn should he go after
this one or this one
is further
yeah black's pawn is further
closer to queening and this pawn's also
closer so of course he's going to go
here
white will push the pawn
continue to push
king will have to move out of the way
and both sides queen at the same time
and then the game should be a draw so
that wasn't the intention when i went
into this so a lot of people are saying
f5 so let's go f5
okay black has to take it because what
happens if king d6
f6 yeah f6 would be the simplest
and then after king d7
white can just go king h5
takes the h pawn and supports the f pawn
so he took here
okay king takes
and now as usual if black king stays
passive he's just going to be squeezed
out king e5 eventually the king will
have to abandon this pawn because of
black having to make a move so he goes
king b5
now this is this position occurred in
the game so what now
if king e5
and that's why i had to calculate
carefully because of king e5 black goes
king c4 and what happens now
we each have pawns on both sides of the
board
nobody wants it to be their move in this
position
i don't want it to be my move when i run
out of pawn moves and he doesn't want it
to be his move
so what could i do
if i play a4
what does black play
b5
uh yeah a5 is possible
a5 is one sorry for black yeah no a5
then what is white to after a5 now black
loses
we do this symmetrical we move
symmetrical h3
not h4 h5 but either h3 h5 h4
and now white takes upon
and wins but instead after king c4 a4
what can black play
a6 a6 is possible
and then if h3
a5 but the thing is
here
what's the result of this position
if a6
mm-hmm the result of this position
h4 or a5 people are saying online both
win correct
h4
and black has to play h5 and white goes
a5 or black goes a5 white goes h5
so again this position after a4 black
doesn't want to go a6 either this and
this is similar to the game as well
black only has one move here
we should know it by now right
someone says a5 again if a5 white goes
h3 and when it's symmetrical then the
side whose move it is will end up having
to
give way
um
a6 uh then we already we just did that
when white could play a5
or white could play h4 either way
leaving black so a5
and then black plays h5 white plays h4
so people are saying h5 so this one cuts
down on white's possible moves on the
king side with the pawn
so now
black remains with possible two moves
for this pawn
white has two moves for that pawn
but it's white's move so there's no way
white's going to lose a move here if h3
black goes h4 and then if
a5 a6
or if white case h goes h4 black goes a5
or if white goes a5
black goes what is black play after a5
important
this was the key point why h5 was
necessary
h4 very good taking away white's option
of the two
two pawns
okay and then now we can see since it's
white's move here
a6 h3 and black winds
or h3 a6 in black winds
so all of this shows now you can
probably ascertain from all that what
what move white should actually play
here
king e5 would have lost the game
but i played what do you think
king e6 now all the same
positions
white will have lost one tempo
so this was it was nice to be able to
carry out this exact exact trebuchet in
an actual tournament game of course with
these pawns on the sides of the board
so black played king c4 i played king e5
and here he he tried h5 let's see some
of the other moves we already now know
basically what's happening but if a6
what does white play
[Music]
did he
h3 very good
h3
and now both sides pawns only have one
move
and each and there's no way white can or
black rather can lose a move
so black loses for instance a5 a4
h5 h4 and king has to give way
okay what if he plays a5
what do i play here
i have now two winning moves
oh no sorry i only have one actually
yeah
yeah sorry i actually do have two
winning moves yeah h4 or
a4 right a4 and then black has to play
h5 and then h4
uh or white could start with um
after after um a5 white could start with
a4
and then after h5 h or is that what i
just said well after a5 white could
start with
h4 and then after h5 a4 or after a4 h5
either way it's very easy to calculate
count the moves but
so he played h5
what do i do here
if i go h4 i'm leaving black's bishop
with the choice of one
or two
so we never want to do that
i want to keep my pawn having the choice
and if his pawn is going to have the
choice i'm going to restrict the choice
so after h5 there's only one move for
white to win
and not lose in fact
a4 yeah i need to prepare
to restrict
the a pawn in case he restricts me
so now this pawn only has one choice i
will restrict him so his choice his pawn
only has one choice
and then you can see that either way
h3a6
or a6h3 black will run out of moves so
what actually happened in the game after
a4 he played a5
now it's clear what white should do h4
and the black king had to give away and
the game finished like this
i cut his king off from coming back
and then i played d5
so white can queen first or even slow
black down a little bit with king c3
and then
just queen the pawn
checkmate
so that's how the game ended well
after d5
okay so
let's now go to
one of the nicest
endings
on this theme
that i've ever seen
probably some of you have seen this
before possibly i don't know how many
people are on here but possibly some
people have seen this before if you have
uh let other people
have a chance to try to guess the moves
um
this was the game henneberger versus
nimzovich from winter tour 1931.
it's uh
well
who is stands better here what do you
think
in general terms
black yeah of course black stands better
just in general terms we have a strong
knight against a bad bishop bishop is
blocked by these pawns
white has a weakness of the light
squares because all the pawns are
basically all the relevant pawns are on
the lights are in the dark squares and
the bishop is a dark squared bishop
black also has more space
white pawns are weaker
but you can have positions where you're
winning but or we're not winning but
rather you're you're better but you're
not winning because you can't break
through
you have no way to make progress
sometimes
so how does black make progress here
okay you could go knight to d6
but
what's the idea
you want to attack the pawn on c3
white could then just go here right
and then what
see
knight p1
come back here
someone says knight c2
okay
and we go here
king there and then here
what now
knight a3 okay
i actually did
just a second
926
hmm
immediate 96 yeah
yeah i guess you have to go king e2 king
king here and then bishop c1 trapping
the knight
what now you want to sacrifice
yeah it's odd that i didn't see this
immediately idea before
okay
i'm not sure this works let me go back
though also
knight t6 bishop d2 knight b5
yeah i mean there's no choice but to
bishop e1 knight a4
52
knight c2 king king of
king e2 yeah
yeah i didn't i didn't i don't know i
didn't look at 96 because i assumed that
there's that black has to play the way
he did
um
96 uh
maybe let's see
knight a3 maybe bishop f2 here it might
be right but then there's yeah knight b1
and then bishop b1
yeah it looks like we can actually just
wait with bishop f2 you're right
and then if a3 then white can play
king f2
and then after king e4 king e2
king c6 yeah and then you can
yeah
king c6
king e2 uh king e2
king d6 king f2 and doesn't manage to do
triangulation
okay
it's not looking like it works just
knight 96 the immediate transfer of the
knight
here yeah bishop f2
so okay what else could black play
so tariff says king c6 so what we want
to do is if we get this position
with it white to move what happens
the white king has to step back right
because otherwise these pawns are lost
and white can never play a3 because then
black will easily bring the knight to b5
and all those
positions will be winning for black
so yeah that's what nimzovitch did he
did
um
he triangulated the king
white has to step back with the king
because again the bishop can't move and
so first success was to make it white's
move here now white went king e2
and now with the white king having been
pushed back one
one rank
now was the time for the 96 move
threatening to come into e4
okay so the white king had to come back
he can't allow the king into e4
for instance bishop d2 king e4
and if white tries to defend with a
bishop like this we already saw this the
knight comes in and then knight b1 and
white runs out of moves for instance
knight bishop d2 takes and king f3
so we can't white king can't let the
king the black king into e4
so after king 296 he went back to e3
okay black gained a tempo now by this by
losing a tempo he gained a tempo now he
continued with his knight maneuver
okay bishop d2 we already had this
position when it's white's move
when it's white's move
the bishop
moves to e1
but it's blacks move
black goes knight a3 now the bishop
can't go to e1
what happens after bishop e1
yeah now you can go into the king and
pawn ending even though the black knight
is
stronger than the bishop sometimes you
need to be ready to transform advantages
so after king e4
king e2
and now what a key point that without
this move the game would be drawn
a3 yeah
a3
and then the white king has to give way
so
here white plays bishop c1
what now
very good avinash
knight to b1
okay white can defend the pawn bishop b2
only move because again you can't go
bishop d2
the king and pawn inning is again
winning for black
so white had to play bishop b2
and now
a3
okay bishop has to go to a1
i know what's happened
the black knight is trapped but so is
the white bishop
so how does this change the situation
and this is the only way for black to
make progress the immediate 96 as we saw
because of that bishop if tomov looks
like what black can't make progress that
way
so what has happened now both pieces are
trapped
what would if what would happen if it
were white's move
yeah tren says now i think i might be
able to triangulate my king in we want
it to be white's move again
white's going to win this night
but in the meantime black will win that
pawn if black can make the white king
give way
so
knight to d2 doesn't work because black
would
come in here but white would stop him
so
we don't want to give up the night we're
going to lose we'll lose that knight but
we need the white king going far away in
order to take it
so first king c6 well he did king d6 but
king c6 would work the same way
king d6 king e2
king c6
and now white's problem is that white
can't triangulate as well if white
writes these basically e3 and d5 are
related squares if white tried to avoid
occupying e3 then the knight would get
out
and then after this move
what's the simplest well
okay
black black could obviously play knight
e4 but the simplest would be knight b3
taking the bishop or queening the pawn
if white takes the knight
so white had to go back
to d1 because well if he knew if he goes
king e3 black is going to come in with a
king anyway and it will come to the same
thing but with black up a couple of
tempi so he went king d1
to go take the knight as fast as he
could
okay now kim king d5
king c2 king e4
king takes b1
king f3
black's going to take this pawn it looks
like it's over
black takes the pawn moves the king out
of the way and queens the g-pawn
but white had still a chance and he used
it any ideas what could white do
he has an extra bishop at least for the
moment
bishop b2 island says bishop b2
yeah james i don't think this was new
this black bishops and triangulation
were not new in chess at the time
but still
it was well known but
still this was a very artistic example
bishop b2
white frees the bishop
and now if black takes g3 at least white
gets the bishop free
and then maybe comes to c5 and with d5
can stop black's g pawn
and push then oops and then push the a
the a pawn
so he played bishop b2 black had to take
the bishop to avoid that happening and
now a4
so now comes the pawn race and here
every tempo counts
king takes g3 a5
what do we play here
black king clearly needs to move away
from
uh in front of the pawn
but where
take f4
trenches to move to h2 and joseph says
to take f4
and avinash says king h2
so if we're going to move our king out
from in front of the pawn in general we
would like to also take a pawn right
um okay also
big boy shaq says king f2
so we can't be checked
so in general if we're going to move our
king out from in front of the pawn we
need we could take a pawn as well but
nimzovich played king h2 which was more
accurate and we'll see why
it's uh makes a big difference
what now both sides advance pawns
now if we imagine the black king is on
f4 black has an extra pawn white takes
on b2 okay white has to take on b2 black
if the black king's on f4 black has an
extra pawn but it's a tough queen and
pawn ending three against two both kings
are open
so who knows it can probably black
should win but it's it's not easy
but with the king on h2 there's a clear
solution in general if we can go into a
king and pawn ending
that can be mathematically calculated
whereas the queen and pawn ending you
could say well it's better for black but
it may not be winning or at least it's
very difficult and you're going to have
to make many difficult moves for a long
time whereas in the king and pawn ending
usually is just pure mathematics and so
nimzovich calculated when he played king
h2 and saw that after queen g2
forcing the trait of queens now it's
still equal pawns but another race
happens
black is going to take f4 white's going
to take c4
and then we're going to have a race of
the f pawn in the c pawn
and nimzovich had calculated that king
a3 king of three king b4 king f4 king c4
king e4
king b4
f4 c4 we don't need the c pawn or the d
pawn of course
black just pushes
and queens one step one move before
white's pawn queens and then stops the
pawn
so this was a really epic ending
um just first triangulation the invasion
with the knight trapping the ones his
own knight the second triangulation
breaking through with the king
and then the race of pawns to queen the
trait of queens and then a second race
um
yeah and fortunately at the start yeah
this knight d6 this is just to recap
here
um hadn't prepared 96 for some reason
but
it looks like white can just continue
waiting
with this and if black tries to invade
here white can just avoid with this and
there's no way for black to make
progress
knight b1 also allows
this move
and if a3
then black can
white's given away or black has given
away the waiting move so king f2
king e4 king e2
and and white would draw that's why it
was crucial the first triangulation
it was crucial
okay let's do one more um let's see what
i have
oh yes this was um
one of my games
from a few years ago
uh my opponent was a player named dennis
wagner
and uh well we start off with this
position where i'm worse obviously i
have two pawns against three but it
should be a draw well actually let's
just skip ahead a little bit because
i made a few mistakes and then i got
into trouble
this was also in time pressure
um
i made this mistake my opponent didn't
take advantage of reach this position
again
and i again here i played queen c6 which
was a mistake
uh i had to continue waiting
uh and my opponent plays
queen e2
and then i realized okay we're both very
low in time that
f3 is a threat and probably i'm losing
so i took one last chance which was
queen takes g6
there's no way to stop f3 otherwise
other than queen a4 but after queen a4
my queen is
stuck after g5
and i can't i have to constantly stop f3
and stop the queen from appearing on the
long diagonal or the third rank and it's
impossible to do for instance queen d4
queen c2 would be a good way to make
progress
threatening queen c6
and
if queen d5 then queen a3
and this pawn or f3 will come next
or if queen b4 then queen c6 followed by
either coming in with a queen or taking
that pawn
so i took my last chance queen takes g6
what does black do now he plays he
checks f3 king h1 that's the point
and what now
does black take on f2
what happens if queen takes f2
and be careful
many of us probably see the idea but
it's white's move if queen takes f2 what
happens
queen g4 so you want to give away your
queen the problem is after queen g4 hg
white has a move hg and then loses
checkmate next
queen g3 the king king can take
and now white unfortunately has to make
a move h4 or has a move
queen g5 you're getting closer
but after king takes h4
black can take
with the queen and avoid stalemate
anyone else there's there's a move that
i intended if he took on f2
queen f6 that's the only way forcing
black to
uh take this pawn first if king g3 white
can
also force him to take the pawn after
queen g5 and then next move queen g4
either way or queen
or in this case if king h3
then queen f5 and queen g4 with
stalemate so of course he didn't fall in
for that even though both players were
in
time pressure we were playing on the
increment until the end of the game he
wasn't going to fall for that so queen
f1
okay i obviously can't let him take my
f pawn with check so i played queen g1
and now black takes here either way the
queen trait is forced
and reaches this ending
can black win this ending and how
if so
first move is clear okay king g4 i move
my king back
but what's the what's the winning plan
for black if if he can win
yeah black could try to bring the king
to e2 that's because clearly the king
can't penetrate on the king's side
there's no way through there's no space
over there
the white king just waits over there so
black king will not be able to go that
way so have to go to e2
in the meantime white can go after this
pawn
so how is this going to happen though
okay black started with king f4 i went
king h2 he repeated moves one time
that's fine to gain time
and now
he made a move which
i think he well because of the time
pressure
i think he just he couldn't find the win
and so he played a move which normally
uh
you know that you're not go you
shouldn't play this move because now the
pawn is one step closer
so it's a draw after this move
he only played that because he just
needed to find some some move
and he didn't see the win and
he couldn't repeat another time of
course so
how does black wind know h4
draws
if black goes king e4 what happens
people are saying a lot of different
moves
what happens after king e4
king g3 right
neither side wants it to be their move
here this is related squares king on e4
and
e4 and g3
but here it's black's move so it's a
draw
if he tries h4
well
then he should be careful because if he
tries to continue playing for a win
what do i do here
even here it's still a draw but
what do i do here
yeah the trebuchet again
king e2 is if if black plays king e2
then king g3 and white wins because it's
black smooth
black would be smart to go back with the
king though and then it's still a draw
because the king stays in front of the
pawn white wins the pawn but it's
drawn ending
so
so king e4 doesn't work black needs this
position king e4 king g3 with
black needs this position with it being
white's move
so what else could black do
some people said king h5
now if i go king g3 there would be
king e4
and here it's white's move and so white
loses because i have to move my king
away and if i go after the h-pawn
i'm not in time he takes the pawn and
wins
and meanwhile if i try to defend
passively it doesn't work as usual the
king will be pushed out and black will
win the pawn
so after king f5 though i have a defense
what is it
yeah i don't know how to turn off the
it's not my computer i don't know how to
turn off the auto
the whatever you call it
but those moves are of course not always
correct those are just very
basic suggestions from computers so it's
no point in paying attention to them
very good innovative
king h3
and trent king h3
avoiding occupying the
the square g3
and then if king e4 king g3 once again
with a draw
and if king of four white repeats and of
king g5 king g3
so going back to this well now we've
probably been able to figure it out
because we already tried all the
reasonable moves
king g4 only repeats to back to where we
were king of five is met by king h3
king e4 is met by king g3 so we left
we're left with king e5
now white's problem is that
if white goes king g3 king e4 and we
already know that white's losing there
if white goes king h3
what does black do now
this is the point why king f5 is better
than king f5
king d4
again avoiding e4 this square is
basically mind you don't want to enter
that square before the white king goes
to g3
but from e5 black can also
continue his plan of going around and
threaten that plan
while avoiding e4
so now if king g3
black is able to play king e4 and put
white in zugswang king has to move away
then king comes in black king comes in
if white tries to go after the h pawn
then black is going here
and taking the pawn
and if white goes back again we already
saw passive defense doesn't work
so the solution was king e5
if king g3 king e4 and if king h3 king
d4
and after king h4 then this and after
king ju3 then king e4
so
okay this is
the topic has been basically
losing a move we see that in many of
these cases you do want to gain a move
for instance in the nimsovich example
there were races where every tempo
counted
there were situations in all of these
endings where every tempo counted but
also
um
[Music]
a distinguishing feature of end games
compared to middle games is that
sometimes you don't want to have the
move
very often in fact most end games
involve this this theme at some point so
we and we we saw this also in bishop
endings it's not only pawn endings it's
very common in pawn endings but
we see it in the in in other endings as
well
i hope you've enjoyed this
uh have a happy thanksgiving this has
been grand master brian smith with the
st louis chess club bringing you insane
in the end game
[Applause]
[Music]
you